my favorite street dish is drunken
noodle spicy aromatic flavorful to me
it's a perfect dish look at that
boom
bam
hey there friends my name is arnold and
i am a chef and restaurateur but today
you are in my home kitchen i have been
spending quite some time celebrating and
discovering the flavors of my mom's
homeland of thailand and today i'm gonna
dig a little deeper than a recipe and
we're gonna make rice noodles from
scratch
right how cool is that not only are we
doing that but i'm going to show you a
fun street side condiment called
which is a chili vinegar sauce and in
addition to all of that we're going to
combine it and make a drunken noodle
what a fantastic day
if you can make traditional italian
pasta at home you definitely can make
rice noodles at home as well it's
surprisingly really really easy and
doesn't take very many ingredients so
what i've got here is about one
cup of super fine rice flour that i'm
placing into this mixing bowl and with
that i'm gonna add one third of a cup of
tapioca starch then i'm gonna take my
half teaspoon and sprinkle a little bit
of salt right on top and mix it all
together until it's fully incorporated
consistently now i'm going to take one
and a quarter cup of water and just
drizzle it in until it's fully
incorporated and it looks almost like
the consistency of coconut milk i mean
it looks really watery and loose but
trust me guys that's how it should be
all right now that my noodle batter is
ready it is time to actually make the
noodles so what i have here are cake
tins these are about nine or eight inch
cake tins and you can use round or
square don't stress it however mine are
nonstick and if you can't find nonstick
just use your regular pins that you have
and get some spray it'll be fine now
moving on i have this ladle and i'm
going to take some of my rice noodle
batter maybe about two and a half or
three ounces and pour it gently into my
tins until the bottom is thinly coated
oh look at that
how fun
now that i have a thin layer of rice
noodle batter in the bottom of my tins
i'm ready to take it to the steamer okay
so to cook these noodles we're gonna
steam them and what i have here is my
steam basket now i have a pretty
hardcore steam basket and if you don't
have the steam basket do not stress out
trying to find it use whatever steaming
vessel you have my only bit of advice is
don't let the water touch the surface of
the tin so what i'm gonna do
is place my noodles right into the
middle of the steam basket just like
that
one more row
and the lid now just let these noodles
steam for about two to three minutes
until they're completely cooked through
oh i'm excited
whoa it's steamy isn't it oh
my goodness it worked when you see the
noodles bubble up like that and my
glasses fog up like this you know we're
ready
okay guys the noodles are cooked now
what needs to happen is you need to let
these cool down because if they're still
hot and try to work with them they're
going to fall apart and it's also safer
for your hands just a nice gentle peel
off one corner and right off of the tin
oh my god you guys we just made rice
noodles look at this
how cool right here's a little fun
tidbit these rice noodles are very
versatile you can keep them as sheets
and make those beautiful vietnamese
summer rolls you could also cut them
thin for noodles for pad thai or noodle
soup like pho but for this particular
recipe we're gonna do today i like a
thicker noodle so all i'm gonna do now
is just take this pizza cutter and cut
nice
thick slices like so back and forth oh
my goodness look at that how fun you
guys look at that it is a fresh rice
noodle
we did it
rice noodles yay
[Music]
let's talk condiments they are almost as
equally important as the main dish
itself when it comes to eating sweet
food in thailand and there are tons to
choose from but i love this one the most
it is called piknum song it's a chili
vinegar sauce it's bright acidic tangy
full of vinegar and spice and it really
cuts well with the richness of the soy
in the drunken noodle so what i have
here are some serrano chilies and you
can also use jalapenos or whatever
pepper you find at the store i have some
sliced garlic right here generous amount
three to five cloves why not just do it
all right half a teaspoon of salt and
half a teaspoon of sugar then i have one
cup of white distilled vinegar all of
this into my mason jar boom boom boom
boom
and that's it guys my pink num song
it'll keep in the fridge for as long as
you want but trust me it's not going to
last very long now that this is done
it's time for the main event let's get
started on our quick deal
our drunken noodle
when it comes to thai street food there
are a couple items that have made their
name around the world but for me my
favorite street dish is drunken noodle i
love the richness i love the dark soy i
love the tang of the condiments to me
it's a perfect dish but to get to that
point we have to have the base sauce so
what i have here is oyster sauce
and i have this it's a seasoning soy and
it is delicious
now i have one tablespoon of fish sauce
and i have this black dark soy sauce now
this stuff is pretty special it's pretty
thick like molasses it's dark it's
caramely it has a nice rich dark flavor
to it and i'm just going to add about a
half a cup of that into this as well so
i'm stirring this all together and that
is it guys this is our sauce for our
cookie oh
it's time to cook so i have a wok here
but if you don't have a wok don't freak
out don't go buy one use what you've got
use a saute pan use a cast iron just
something that has a surface that
distributes heat so what i've done here
is i have my flame on medium heat and i
have a little bit of neutral oil this is
vegetable oil and i'm going to coat the
bottom of my wok and let it heat up
you're probably wondering how i know the
oil is ready you can smell it and also
little bubbles start to bubble up in the
oil and that's right when you know it's
good to go i'm going to add about a
quarter of an onion that's been thinly
sliced to about maybe six ounces of
chicken and today i am using chicken
thighs now the reason why i'm using
chicken thighs is because i like dark
meat there's a lot more flavor in my
opinion and it also doesn't dry out
oh man this is starting to look really
good already the chicken is halfway done
and now i'm going to add some more
flavor this is just some garlic
nice and fragrant and some thai chili
peppers now be careful with these not
only are they spicy but when they hit
the heat they're going to release an
aroma and they're going to get you user
beware
now i'm going to let the garlic and the
chilies come alive a little bit and i
want to talk to you about thai basil
thai basil is very licoricey in flavor a
little anisee if you will and there's
really not a true substitute if you
can't find it this is what makes squishy
mouth so i have a generous portion of
thai basil that i'm gonna just hand rip
and place right into the wok chinese
broccoli has a very distinct flavor as
well the stems are a little bitter and
the tops are a little sweet like pea
sheets if you can't find chinese
broccoli i like to use tuscan kale you
can also just use broccoli the options
are endless wow there's a lot going on
here already guys check that out oh my
goodness this house smells insane
so much flavor so much fragrance so much
yum all right we're at a good place i'm
going to add the tops of my chinese
broccoli and some red bell peppers
[Music]
now i'm going to let this cook down for
about a minute so everything is nice and
soft and married
now that the flavors have all become one
it's time to add my noodles
come on now noodles and now it is time
to get saucy guys let's pour about three
tablespoons of this beautiful hot quinoa
sauce right on top of my nudes
and magic is about to happen
look at that
boom bam whoa you guys that is it check
it out my beautiful drunken noodle
oh my goodness look at how beautiful
this is i also have here my chili
vinegar sauce and a little bit of fried
garlic that i wanted to top right onto
the plate sprinkle sprinkle we made good
deal
drunken noodles from beginning to end
here is my beautiful and tart
chili vinegar sauce that i'm just gonna
drizzle a little right on top
salivation nation already i haven't even
eaten it yet let's do this ready
[Music]
oh my goodness you guys there's so much
flavor and this sauce on top of it that
tartness the acidity really cuts the
sweet soy as well it's so perfect this
is such a fun dish
well we just had quite the day didn't we
we made rice noodles from scratch a
delicious tart and bright chili vinegar
sauce and brought it all together to
create this magic right here my gorgeous
drunken noodle
and when you make this not if but when
please comment below or tag me and
follow me at arnoldmintbna on instagram
alright guys i really do want to finish
eating this plate so i'm going to say
goodbye for now and i can't wait to see
you again with more great recipes take
care compliment bye-bye
oh yes
[Music]
you